hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on for honor getting today
really wasn't much just a lot of balance
talk which of course we all do love I
love that the DES are a lot more
transparent and he's upcoming dead
streams and stuff like that but you've
got some season nine changes coming as
well some other balanced changes may be
coming in the near future maybe towards
December or January and stuff like that
so let's get started with today's video
first off want to start with saying
Happy Thanksgiving to all the American
people or anybody else that celebrates
it throughout the world happy
Thanksgiving guys hope you guys have a
great day with that but yeah beef action
with the most amount of ranked wins will
get an XP boost for this week's event
challenge so if you do want to play some
rain to get some wins get everybody else
in the faction some XP boots and stuff
like that go for it
next up is the Black Friday sale now
until November 6th all executions and
masks are going to be discounted so get
them before the sale is over and yes
that means all executions and all masks
which is really cool and the content of
the week is elite outfits now these
really aren't my cup of tea but if you
do want to buy them you can they're
gonna be sunlights here men mesmerizing
moth snake eater and kite queen I
totally ruined that name but those are
gonna be the foreword that's for the
Nights viking samurai and the woman so
if you do want to get some so if you do
want to get yourself some elite outfits
you can next up is balance changes and
these are gonna be from season 7 so we
could see all the data that we saw
before now the last time they showed a
state of balance it was pretty bad got
received really badly but the dev showed
it to us and they decreased the ranking
ow so instead of it being the top 2.5
percent in duels
it is now platinum rank from above to
get a lot more of an accurate game sheet
and this is going to be the data table
on screen and basically what this is is
that it's every character versus every
other character in the game and their
win percentage so basically as an
example at the top we have valkyrie
fighting conquer which is a 40% when but
if conqueror is fighting Valkyrie is a
60% win basically you don't have to look
at bold numbers they're all gonna be
multiple they're all going to somehow
add up to 100 so if somebody has a 40%
win against a hero the opposite is gonna
happen as a 60% but going off the data
this means that if a valkyrie were to
duel a conquer conquer has a 60% win
chance while valkyrie has a 40% win
change just based off the duels from
platinum rank and above some very low
numbers that you may want to look at our
law bringer against conquer which is a
29% for law bringer that being I believe
in the 70
I believe for conquer warlord vs.
conquer is 31 PK vs are Musha is 35 and
berserker versus caucus 39 I think this
says a little bit about conquer and
warlord may be a potential nerf to conch
and a buff to warlord in the future not
entirely sure but this is just data and
they don't look at all of this stuff
remember that because that would make
this game very bad if they did but
looking over to the side we have the far
right and that is the overall rating
meaning conquerors at the top going off
the data for the best in duels from
platinum ranking above and with PK
Noguchi in warlord being at the bottom
three with 46% and below now remember
this is the overall rate basically
taking all the numbers dividing it
getting your average stuff like that
with remember these characters are at
the bottom with conch at the top and
like I said I have to reiterate this
multiple time so that people understand
the devs don't balance this game solely
on the game data shown in this table
there are way other sources that we'll
get into in a little bit later that they
do take it in consideration for example
we have the tier list made by multiple
competitive players on our / competitive
for honor on reddit and the top one is
currently game play right now as of
today and the bottom one is back in
January so very big change now you can
take a look at this and see some of the
tier list that they think that the
competitive players who compete for
actual money in these tournaments that
need to know how the game is played how
would they would suit their tier list
but some changes between the two is that
Valkyrie can say Berserker warden and
Highlander and a lot more have moved up
this list a lot with conquer being STR
now and Raider and cheveux key moving
down to C tier and almost all the Wulin
are being a tier except J - who is in
upper B which is pretty interesting
remember all these tiers are made up of
competitive players who constantly play
this game for money so you can take
their not since they do have a lot of
Nod you can take this with a grain of
salt or you can I personally liked over
this tier list a lot since that I do
believe that they have very good
knowledge of this game and I like to use
this stuff a lot but this could be up
for debate
next is the 44 win rate for Dominion
most simple things is that Kent a is
still number one he was number one in
the last state of bounce and he still is
today
so very good pick a very good win rate
for him
shego key PK and gladiator at the bottom
very understandable clad is horrible on
a 4v4 mode I should know so I have
completely understanding he's at the
bottom
for you understandable shougo ki and PK
can also understand his well should go
ki just because he really doesn't have
much to do anyway and then next is the
competitive four before dominion
tearless that the player that the
competitive players made is well not
much to really say here I definitely
grew at the current earless Nobu she and
shaman make a really good combo in
fourth before with the bleed damage that
being shaman can make saw faints and to
bleed and nobody does more damage
because the opponent is bleeding because
of her passive ability or the opposite
than Buu she bleeds them shaman gets the
bite it's a gg right there and most of
most if not all the Wulin are in a tier
right now but that obviously could
fluctuate it's only been about a month
so far so that may change because maybe
people aren't just entirely used to the
characters but I think after a month
people will be the first question in the
Q&A that they did was about woollen
bouncing and this was talking about
their win in pick right now this wasn't
in the chart I don't believe but the
devs had their own little chart that
they have showed for the season 8 state
of balance which I'll probably release
after season 9 begins but so far for the
data all the Wulin have about a 50% win
rate and stuff like that so pretty even
except JJ who's in the high 60s so this
may be changed this doesn't mean a nerf
to JJ just yet but it could be coming
soon and the devs are on top of looking
at JJ's and shallow ends damage for the
next couple of weeks and maybe doing
adjustments as needed because I've seen
a lot of people in the comments as well
talking about shaolin's damage being a
bit too high for his fast lights and
JJ's damage being a bit too high as well
especially he's out of stamina punished
a few things they're looking at is the
heavy feign timing and 33 millisecond
attack changes so when Ken Zeta is a
top-heavy unblockable he has a certain
amount of time before he can faint it
before he can no longer faint it and has
to commit to the move you may have
noticed that the window to either not
parry or parry a move can be very short
and almost millisecond timings before
you can actually change it so this may
be a little bit of a change eventually
in the future making the parry timing
window and not parry time window just a
little bit bigger for players because
I've been in situations like that Raider
throws a zone and I have maybe about a
second if less to period because he
doesn't faint it and stuff like that so
that might be changed and next is the 33
milliseconds attack changes this is
going to be changing timings of moves
all moves are in increments of 100
examples are 400 milliseconds 500 and
600 milliseconds stuff like that they're
going to be working around and playing
with this at the moment on their little
test server that they have and they
might be making moves 450 m/s instead of
500 or
466 it's a little bit smaller timing
numbers I personally like this because
some people like to complain that 400 is
a bit too fast if a 500 is a bit too
slow so 450 might be that perfect middle
ground they also talked about test
servers and if there should be more and
hopefully they will add some in the
future there is a net there wasn't any
confirmation on that but hopefully some
console players we can get some as well
to be really nice and also talked about
halting the out of stamina stamina if
that makes a little bit of sense so when
conker bashes you and you're out of
stamina he will actually drain your
stamina of course because it is a Bosch
attack they might make it so that it
actually just stalls their stamina right
where it is and then goes back to regen
instead of just draining it because I
can totally understand if you're being
completely punished by a Centurion or
anybody with some type of Bosch and
usually can't get your stamina back to
flight there was a small bit of a tease
for the season 9 shoe goki rework but
basically the devs just said that you
that all Shikoku players will be pleased
to actually be able to fight people and
not play a very defensive turtle I don't
really know what that means I don't know
forget more unblockable so I'm tough
with belly bump or head butt or whatever
was happening but either way I'm
completely excited for any type of
change dish you go key he's been needing
it for a while and other changes are
that Raider and Centurion might be
seeing some interesting changes in
season 9 sent having the ability to
faint as heavy unblockable possibly at
multiple different times are very
similar to what they talked about with
shougo key from last week and nothing is
conquered yet like I said and Raider
might get some changes but nothing too
dramatic like a rework maybe getting
some small walks here and there because
he's actually very good in breach
especially for clearing minions so he
does play a lot of mid game for breach
so they'll most likely slowly buff him
until he's viable in all game mode so I
probably won't be expecting a rework for
season 9 so any other Raider players
probably won't be expecting that either
just a small buffer to every so often
and then lastly is that shamans bite
maybe nerve soon maybe in season 9 maybe
not but it's not her damage it's
actually her animation so you can't
really get mad damage after her bite
Shaun bleeds the person goes for the
bite and then after the bite happens you
can may be getting a couple heavies or
something like that depending on your
character this might be nerfed because
if planned successfully can really down
a person's health and maybe even kill
them let me know your thoughts on this
let me know what you guys would change
in season 9 that's gonna be the question
of the week if you guys have had to make
any changes for upcoming patch in the
next couple weeks for season 8 or a
season 9 change or something like that
let me know what you guys would change
maybe you want our Musha have a nerf of
a certain move or should go you gets a
certain buff of this move or etc stuff
like that lesson on the comments boats
get a discussion going guys like the V
if you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
I covered the informational side of
fallen or that being balance changes
hero updates patch notes leaks all the
stuff the informational site or for
honor I like the cover but that guys my
two most recent videos would be on
screen if you guys do want to check that
out thing guys for watching the video
happy Thanksgiving everybody peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]